good morning and welcome to cloud on air
Google clouds live weekly webinar series
where you can hear from product experts
engineers customers and even
sustainability enthusiasts like us my
name is Chris Talbott I'm in the product
marketing organization at Google cloud
and my name is Anna Square and I'm part
of the data center sustainability team
and we're gonna be talking about
sustainability today specifically what
do cloud providers like Google do to
reduce the environmental impact of their
operations and then what does that do
for our customers and our developers in
improving their own sustainability
posture when they use our cloud you can
ask questions live in the platform at
any time there's Googlers behind the
scenes that will answer them or will
address the questions at the end of the
session you ready to go it's good to
start all right so why building on
environmentally responsible cloud
matters and the reason that N and I are
really here today from a sustainability
perspective and from a Google cloud
perspective is sustainability is one of
the core values across Google from the
beginning actually embedded in one of
our mission statements is this idea that
we want to work to empower everyone
everyone from governments to businesses
to enterprises to individuals to use
Google technology in a way that they can
make the world a more sustainable place
and when you think about that challenge
and that mission statement it's really
more important than ever before because
whoever you are whether you're a
government or a business or individuals
we are all facing an incredible
challenge when it comes to improving our
sustainability and reducing the impact
on the environment so the earth is
warming at an alarming rate due to
increasing greenhouse gas emissions and
we're seeing the impact of that in the
environment in the form of melting
IceCaps and desert vacation and you know
more volatile weather that we've been
experiencing and we're also using
resources at an alarming rate so in 2017
the demand for resources was 1.7 times
the amount that the earth can actually
sustain so this idea this linear economy
which you're gonna address a little bit
in in the context of data centers yes
this linear economy idea where we
extract resources we use them and then
we just waste them
we're very quickly coming to a point
where we're gonna hit limits in terms of
the resources that we need to use and
the reduction of those resources so when
we think about becoming more sustainable
sustainable in our operations is really
kind of two sides of a coin it's one can
we be more efficient and reduce the
amount of resources that we use and then
two can we transition to low or zero
carbon energy solutions in order to
power our operations right and across
Google from our hardware teams to the
buildings that our employees work in to
the data centers that support everything
from search to ads to YouTube to all of
our customers on Google cloud platform
and G suite we're trying to reduce our
environmental impact and today we're
going to talk about the data center
portion of that and this is a critically
important portion of that story so we
all know especially the audience on this
webinar who are using cloud tools the
the use of computing resources is
growing exponentially triple digits
year-over-year and millions and millions
of people are coming online new users
are coming online every single month and
all of this computing power is supported
at the end of the day by data centers
whether it's a data center in your
closet of your startup or it's the hyper
scale huge facilities that companies
like Google or Amazon or Microsoft use
to support all of their customers and
because this the computational need is
growing so have the data centers and
it's grown to you know some estimates
have it about 2% of the world's
electricity usage so this is obviously a
major opportunity for us in order to
power these data centers and use
resources for these data centers more
efficiently to
the environmental impact and data
centers in particular have proven to be
an area where innovation has amazing
impact so between 2000 and 2005
electricity usage and data centers grew
90% annually so incredible amounts but
from 2010 to 2014 it only grew 4% that's
largely due in part to the technology
innovation but also because you know
sort of the transition and the advent of
these hyper scale cloud providers that
can use electricity in a far more
efficient manner so proper efficiency
afterwards yeah
definitely we'll get back into that so I
guess the point I'm trying to make is
you know data centers in particular and
then the cloud represents a huge
opportunity for us to reduce the
environmental impact and for our
customers to reduce their own
environmental impact so I want to kind
of double down on this the idea of where
the cloud in particular and Google Cloud
fits into this story and you kind of
requires that we go back a little bit to
the where Google started so as we saw
our business growing and it being a
digital first business growing
exponentially we saw that we needed
energy to power that business that made
sense both from a non environmental
perspective and a business perspective
which is one of the reasons why we focus
on renewable energy purchases that
you're going to talk about mm-hmm and
we've seen our business grow
exponentially and the computing
resources that we need to fuel our
business grow exponentially and yeah not
everyone is supporting 7 billion you are
7 apps with a billion users each like
Google is but everyone is transforming
or revolutionising their business in
some form factor in a digital way and
changing their IT infrastructure that
supports those businesses and as they do
that it's really hard to get access to
clean energy and really hard to get
access to the efficiencies that a cloud
provider can provide so what ends up
happening and what we believe will
happen into the future is that companies
like Google and Amazon and Microsoft and
all the various colocation providers and
other technology companies we're
actually going to be part of the
solution
companies and customers and developers
want to get access to clean energy and
want to be more sustainable in what they
do
so essentially cloud can help you be a
more sustainable business or be a more
sustainable engineer developer on one of
our platforms now when I take the word
sustainable cloud and break that down it
basically we think about it in these
sort of three buckets of areas and this
we're going to talk about in the Google
context but this probably applies to any
cloud provider out there so the first
area is ensuring that you're being as
efficient as possible and using
resources within the data center both
energy and it's like the actual physical
resources that we use like servers and
the waste that that makes second area
which is critically important is
renewable energy and ensuring that you
are focused on getting to zero or low
cost carbon solutions and then finally I
mentioned the linear economy needs to
change based on how much the earth can
support so we need to transition to a
circular economy and reduce the amount
of waste that is eventually hitting a
landfill right so let's talk about the
first area and creating the smartest
data centers that we possibly can so
Google is known for having some of the
most efficient data centers in the world
oftentimes measured at 50% more
efficient than your average data center
and when you think about efficiency in a
data center context a lot of times you
hear the term PUA or power usage
effectiveness right so keep me honest
here Anna this is basically all the
extra stuff you have to use beyond
computing right so PUA as Chris said
stands for power usage effectiveness and
it's the industry-wide metric that we
use to assess the efficiency of a data
center it is calculated by the ratio of
the total energy that you use at your
data center divided by the energy used
only for computing for the IT equipment
so in an ideal world you would want all
your energy consumed just for the IT
equipment but that is virtually
impossible you would always need some
overhead like cooling vent
halation the lights have to be on etc so
it's virtually impossible to get to
purely equal one yeah but the goal is to
get to a peewee that is the closest to
one than you can and at Google since we
first started building our data centers
that was a main focus for us because we
wanted to the most sustainable energy
that you use is the energy that you then
don't write so reducing that overhead to
to a minimum is a goal that we have
worked we have been working very hard to
and our PUA has been on a 12 month
trailing average of 1.1 and just for
comparison purposes the average data
center out there has a PE of 1.7 so
that's a massive difference in the
amount of energy that our data centers
consume compared to the average yeah
it's great and what's the difference
between 1.1 1.1 2 and 2 so the 2 colors
in this in this chart are the
differences between the seasons so in
summer time you need way more cooling
yes that you will need in wintertime so
that's why you see those picks
throughout the seasons but what really
matters is the trailing average over the
last 12 months that averages out all the
differences in the seasons great thanks
for the explanation yeah and we continue
to focus on this and report on these
metrics correct we report on these
metrics and we have even a project with
deepmind to optimize PUA through machine
learning so we continuously look for
opportunities and for new technologies
to optimize our energy consumes
consumption yeah I was gonna mention
that it's so data centers in general
they're kind of tricky beasts in that
they've got environments incredibly
dynamic a model for a cooling system
doesn't apply to another system and data
centers are unique from data center and
data centers so this idea that you can
use you know learning networks in
particular to achieve additional
improvements in data center efficiency
is a great way where some of the other
work within Google is translating into
how efficient we can be correct we have
one of our engineers had the gray
idea of trying machine learnings in our
data centers and deepmind got involved
and it was it was a great learning
experience what we were able to reduce
40% of our cooling energy just by using
machine learning yeah and that's one of
the areas where we innovate but when you
think about all the areas that
contribute to data center efficiency and
reducing that eventual overhead there's
other areas of innovation across our
data centers in particular you know in
some of our data centers where we've
located like Finland where we've located
the data center next to water resource
the Gulf there so we can cool with sea
water and other areas like you know only
manufacturing the parts of the servers
that we actually need none of the
superfluous components are all areas
where Google is innovated in order to
increase the efficiency of our data
centers correct it's not only adjusting
the amount of energy that we use after
building the data center is where we
build a data center how we use the
natural resources that are available in
the area how we can optimize before even
spending those resources and that energy
now being as efficient as possible in
using energy as a key component but
sourcing the right kind of energy is as
much if not more right so a Google we
love moonshots and back in 2012 we
decided that we would match hundred
percent of our consumption with
renewable energy back in the day we
didn't really know how we would do it
but only five years later we achieved
this amazing milestone so last year in
2017 hundred percent of the mao-a towers
that we consumed for our global
operations and that includes data
centers offices everything that we run
was matched with a man with merit hours
of renewable energy and that is kind of
complicated so I'm gonna cover how we do
it and why what what it why it matters
and and how we got there so depending on
how you generate your electricity your
carbon or greenhouse gas emissions are
going to be completely different so
depending on whether you're fueling a
gas power plan or
coal power plan or you're using
renewables to generate that now at our
the amount of greenhouse gases are going
to be completely different
right so generating one more hour with a
coal burning plant versus a windmill
it's completely different however once
the electricity hits the grid there is
no way to differentiate the electrons
that were generated in a coal power
plant versus a windmill and that is
because how grades function and so if
you are if you are a electricity user
that is hooked into the grid as we all
are there is no way that you can
differentiate the type of electricity
that you get from the grid it's all the
electrons are the same so a number of
years ago there was this mechanism that
was created to track the renewal energy
attribute of the male watt hours that
were in the grid and those are called
renewable energy certificates also
commonly known as racks so every time
one male a tower of electricity is
generated one rack one unique rack is
also generated in such a way that you
can track the generation with these
certificates so that is the way that we
are able to track even though we're
hooked into the grid and we get the
power from the grid we're able to track
all the renewable energy that we're
getting so last year we finally match
hundred percent of our electricity
consumption with renewal uses and we
have that amount of renewable energy
credits recs on our portfolio what this
mean real quick on 100 percent match
that means that we have purchased energy
or energy has been renewable energy has
been produced somewhere enough to equal
everything that we've consumed as a
company correct the concept of matching
is is an intermediate solution for what
we would like for the long term so what
basically happens is that a data center
has to run 24/7 and a cloud customer
we can tell them oh sorry the wind isn't
blowing we can serve you that would
never work so we still need the grades
there are currently no technologies that
cancer's 100% of the time renewable
energy to serve hundred percent of the
time the needs of electricity that we
have right so the way that we got to
hundred percent was ensuring that we
were matching 100% of our consumption
with renewable that was generated in the
grades where we operate or elsewhere
that is not the perfect solution but at
Google we like moonshots and so we are
constantly looking for opportunities to
make that 100 percent renewable goal a
hundred percent of the time twenty four
by seven mhm
we'll get there yeah so what this means
for you as a cloud customer when you run
on Google cloud hundred percent of the
electricity that is consumed on your
behalf is actually much with renewable
energy so 100 percent of renewable
energy match this means that we buy a
lot of renewable energy correct so
Google is the largest purchaser of
renewable energy in the world last March
last month we publish that we're around
3 gigawatts of renewable energy and that
makes us almost over 2x the next
purchaser seen on renewable energy and
as we said we talked about matching and
what it means and Google will like to
innovate in an innovation
it also comes not only for the products
or the great tools that we build but it
also comes for the way that we source
renewable energy so we have partnered
with a number of entities utilities
project developers etc to bring new
power into the grid
so this Rex the the renewable energy
certificates that we mentioned are
available on the market you can buy them
off the shelf but that wouldn't be for
us additional and that wouldn't be
bringing new really
generation into the grade so what we do
is that every time we sign a project we
make sure that those projects are new so
we are adding new capacity into the grid
in such a way that our impact is larger
than just buying renewable energy
certificates of the grid so you as a
customer have the certitude that the
power that is being much to your
consumption is actually additional and
it's new capacity that we're bringing
into the grid
yeah so the last piece that we wanted to
cover is that the third pillar that
we've been talking about circular
economy versus linear economy so the
circular economy as Chris explained is
this concept where products do not have
an end of life and create waste so the
the typical or the classic way of
manufacturing and of using products is
linear you take resources from the earth
you produce a product you use it and you
dispose it off it goes to landfill and
that's the end of it the way that
circular economy works is that products
do not have an end of life they products
materials components they always keep
the maximum value that they can at all
times in a way that they reenter the
economy and we believe that Google has a
role to play to make that transition
happen and to enable others to also play
on the circular economy principles so at
Google and at the data center team we're
doing this at scale with the hardware
that we deploy at the data centers so
there is a way to manage our hardware in
a circular fashion and we do it through
these four steps so first of all we
refurbish or remanufacture so 19 percent
of the servers that we deployed were
actually refurbished there were not me
so that almost 20 percent of the fleet
is refurbished material then we reuse or
redistribute what this means is that
certain components of a server might
fail my and get to a level of of non
usability right so instead of changing
the whole server we would reuse or
redistribute those resources and
refurbish the certain pieces that are
important for the server to expand its
life and that was up to 52% we also
maintain and prolong and that is a very
similar concept where 75% of the parts
that we use at the data centers were
actually refurbished what those were not
new and the last pillar which I really
like is the repurposing and recycling
some of the components that we use on
the data centers are highly technical
they need to have certain capabilities
and so at some point those those
components are not going to be usable
for the quality standards that we
require and that our customers require
but some of those could be perfectly
usable and completely fit for other
purposes so we safely sell sell those to
the secondary market for others to use
in a way that what could be waste for us
is actually an input for other
industries and so everything that that
can't be refurbished or redistributed or
maintained we recycle it in a way that
it reactors the economy through a
completely different product and we make
sure that we screen all of our suppliers
for recycling and that we recycle
products in the most environmentally
responsible way and close the loop right
and close a little bit so we talked
about kind of the three areas
specifically within the context of
Google cloud but generally I think what
you as developers and IT decision-makers
and buyers of cloud computing technology
should consider when you're thinking
about sustainability in the context of
cloud computing and that's how efficient
the data centers are that support all
those products that you use and the
platforms that you develop on
what kind of energy is going to power
those data centers and then finally what
are those providers doing in order to
ensure that we are doing our best to
reduce the amount of resources that we
use so what does that translate in to
for a customer or a developer or a
business that wants to move to Google
cloud and you know one of the biggest
things is that you get to be carbon
neutral if you use Google cloud for your
compute or the storage of your data so
because we've matched all of the energy
like Anna mentioned that we use with
renewable energy and and that renewable
energy is what is matched with all the
compute and the storage electricity that
we use to support our customers
if you move your compute workloads or
you move your data storage to Google
cloud the emissions associated with that
usage is going to be zero right and I'm
smiley because that's one of the
programs that I'm running and I'm very
proud of because we have been carbon
neutral for over 10 years now and we do
that through renewable energy but also
through high-quality carbon offsets for
those emissions that would still occur
even though the renewable energy
purchases yeah I'd like to think of this
in kind of the lift and shift movement
that's going on within the IT industry
right now so as I mentioned like all
organizations are in some stage of the
process of digitalising their business
they're going for a transformation or a
revolution or they're just trying to
improve some of their current systems by
moving those to the cloud and I think
when you traditionally think about that
movement you think about things like
cost savings performance improvements
efficiency improvements or productivity
and those are great and those will all
come with the move to the cloud but you
know additionally you should think about
what you're doing to impact the
environment in a positive way and if you
lift your workloads and move them to
Google cloud you're definitely impacting
the environment in a positive way
relative to what you could probably do
using your local grid and energy you
would source if you plug-in that server
on-premises write your emissions your
net emissions would be zero which
as we saw the beginning is crucial for
climate change and maintaining that
temperature rise before below two
degrees centigrade so the other thing we
want to talk about which we haven't
mentioned too much is G suite so lots of
organizations use products like Gmail or
Docs or sheets in order to increase
productivity in collaboration with their
teams and if you do that you get all the
benefits of what we're doing across our
data centers from an energy and
efficiency perspective so businesses
that have switched to the G suite of
products they've reported reductions in
their carbon emissions of 65 to 85
percent right and that is the result of
all the programs that we discussed our
renewable energy purchases and our
carbon neutrality and this is the impact
that those businesses saw in their
footprint yeah so not only could you
make your users more productive and more
collaborative and they're tools that
they use on a daily basis you can make
them more sustainable in doing so right
and finally this is kind of a technical
concept but I want to talk about less
energy intensive computation or ability
that's available in cloud computing so
likelihood you've heard of the increase
and the importance of machine learning
and artificial intelligence and how
that's really revolutionizing how
businesses operate and serve their
customers today one of the things that's
unique to machine learning is they're
incredibly computational intensive
workloads and when something's really
computationally intensive it generally
means that it needs a lot of energy to
perform what it's doing and at Google
we've been using machine learning in all
of the products that serve our customers
like search and ads and Gmail for a long
time and in doing that we use
specialized hardware that's been
designed to be as efficient as possible
in using its energy and the metrics that
you use in order to measure that is
something called teraflops per watt yes
so essentially and you can
always correct me if I'm wrong but for
every trillion operations of computation
that these chips will perform what is
the it's essentially per watt of energy
that supports those trillion operations
and you're trying to maximize that in
order to use energy in the most
efficient way possible well we recently
released from a Google Cloud perspective
the availability of something called
cloud GPUs so GPU stands for tensor
processing unit and it's similar to
these machine learning design chips that
we've been using at Google for a long
time so not only do you get you know 15
to 30 X performance improvements and the
computational computations that you're
performing but you also get more energy
and efficient computations when it comes
to those really intensive machine
learning workloads
right then this links back to the fact
that the most sustainable energy is the
one that you don't use and so at Google
we not only work on making our data
centers efficient but also the specific
resources for certain products on cloud
that are available to our customers to
make that efficiency happen and I also
think that this kind of segues into
something that we haven't talked about a
little bit but we can kind of ad-lib
about it right now and that how do you
use products available from Google and
from other providers in order to make
your business more sustainable right
access to something like this for
machine learning workloads that is more
energy efficient using our analytics
tools in order to optimize your supply
chain there's other ways beyond just the
resource use and the energy that we are
sourcing in order to use products from
Google and others to make you a more
sustainable business right so with those
things in mind what can you do what can
you ask of your technology provider in
order to get a good idea of where they
stand from a sustainability perspective
so the first thing and probably the most
important thing is asking them about
their renewable energy commitments and
targets and you want to be specific in
this right because there's different way
that this could take form right there's
a lot of ways that you can get to a
certain percent of renewal energy and we
talked about buying renewable energy
certificates right off the shelf that is
a good question to ask whether the
company that you're considering for your
cloud business is that a company that
purchases new capacity that bring new
capacity to the grid that are focused on
additionality for the renewal energy
purchases or they're just buying of what
is available already are there are
different commitments there are certain
companies that would commit to X percent
renewable by 2020 or 2030 or 2050 it's
up to you to judge what you think is
possible today
and based on what we've done I know it's
challenging I mean I'm not gonna lie we
have a we have a very capable and very
strong team that has been sourcing
renewables for the last five years but
it's something that can be done and
we've we've kind of went all the way to
100% yeah and this gets back to what it
translates into you if the answer is not
a hundred percent renewable energy then
the answer can also not be when you move
your compute there zero carbon emissions
all right I haven't met that then
chances are they won't be able to meet
that right carbon emissions they could
have a carbon neutrality goal and use
carbon offset as an intermediary before
you get to 100% renewable but then
there's also a lot of questions that you
can ask about the carbon offsets that
they're using are those high quality
carbon offsets do they focus on
additionality what type of benefits the
offsets are bringing etc so what is the
carbon intensity of you moving to the
cloud is definitely a question that I
would ask because that's going to affect
your emission inventory and not on your
direct emissions on your upstream
supplier emissions but those are also as
important as your direct emissions yeah
so that that gets to how does your
provider source renewable energy
do they have carbon neutrality targets
we've kind of talked about what you want
to listen for like words like
additionality and totally carbon neutral
and how they get there right
you also get asked your cloud provider
like what else are they doing from an
efficiency or driving sustainability
programs perspective in order to
minimize their environmental impact and
I think you know some of the things that
aren't directly related to you know
renewable energy that Google does like
the refurbishments and the circular
economy principles like these are things
that you could ask your copper foil
provider to get their perspective and
how they approach those challenges
correct a cloud provider uses a lot of
resources and that's not only energy
we've seen how we implement circular
economy practices and that also brings
back to the goal that we have of zero
waste landfill so at Google we want zero
waste to go to a landfill landfill for
us means the last resource that
resources that are trashed and they're
never going to be used again so we want
to avoid that and so company companies
do also have programs that minimize
other environmental impacts and not only
energy and you should definitely ask for
that yeah then finally this idea of
making resources available to help you
as a developer or a customer or a user
of gee sweida and Google cloud platform
be more sustainable yourself I think
this is really interesting because it's
not only can you use the products
available from a cloud provider to in
order to like I mentioned like optimize
your supply chain or do more energy
efficient computations but you know
there are a network of customers who are
trying to hit sustainability targets and
they're incorporating their usage of the
cloud into that process are they doing
their own environmental report like many
companies do now to talk about where
they are within their sustainability
goals right like does your cloud
provider provide the resources for that
part of your business in order to
measure how you're doing from a
sustainability perspective right there's
a lot of questions that you can ask and
definitely how does your cloud provider
help you getting there getting to your
goals is a key one
so let's talk about a few of the
customers who kind of share this
environmentally responsible ethos that
Google has so one customer lush was
super focused on increasing not only
their productivity and the efficiency of
the products that they were using on
their cloud platform they were focused
on finding a cloud provider that aligned
with being a more sustainable company
and having less environmental impact so
not only did wash move their operations
you know functionally from on-premises
to Google cloud platform but throughout
the process they increase their energy
efficiency by I believe it was like 30
or 40 percent so they really believed
that sustainability was an important
part of the process when they moved to
the cloud yeah and by moving to the
Google cloud they also reach that goal
of having their cog won or match by
renewable energy yeah and Etsy a very
similar situation where as a company
they really focused on having a
sustainable platform to support their
customers they have their own
sustainability goals and sustainability
teams that have kind of Northstar
metrics that they want to hit from a
sustainability environmental impact
perspective so you know what's really
interesting about Etsy is they included
this in their evaluation criteria as
they went through the process of
evaluating a cloud yeah like not only
are you looking at how fast VM spin up
on a platform but you're looking at
where does the provider source their
energy like what are the metrics that
your provider if it is focus on in terms
of stainability
so they aligned with the goals right
because EDC also has their own
sustainability goals and renewable
energy goals so having a cloud provider
that would meet also the renewable
energy standards was a key component for
this yeah and a platform like Etsy which
is a you know a digital commerce
experience a lot of the associated
electricity environmental impact that
goes into their business is going to be
associated with that IT infrastructure
and finally this is kind of a fun one I
really think it's interesting to see
we're companies who I should say where
environmental impact or sustainability
related projects or businesses are core
to what they do they're finding areas in
the cloud in order to help them do that
so Makani is actually a Google X company
where they fly these wind kites you know
hundreds of meters in the air it turns
out as anyone who's been on a roof or
hiked anything has experienced that the
wind blows harder
yeah the farther up you go so you can
actually generate wind in your energy
far more efficiently efficiently if you
can capture it high up in the air so
Makani uses Google cloud platform in
order to analyze a bunch of Geographic
and environmental data and essentially
find out where there are areas where
they can tether their kites and generate
the most wind power yeah it's funny how
how they can find the more windy or the
most efficiency with a cloud that is
much hundred percent with renewable
energy yeah so to wrap this up before we
get to the QA what are some things that
we believe that you as a potential user
or a current user of Google cloud can do
now so I think the first thing is to
really figure out what your own company
what their sustainability goals are
because there's a lot of companies who
shares similar goals to Google in terms
of renewable energy and environmental
impact there's two websites that I
include on the slide re 100 are a bunch
of companies who have committed to 100%
renewable energy and we are still in or
a bunch of companies who have committed
to still meeting the Paris agreement
requirements so chances are your company
may or may not have its own
sustainability goals and the IT
infrastructure or the developments or
the apps that you build it's gonna have
a part in that totally correct yes and
setting up your goals and if you haven't
set those up yet we'd really encourage
you to go through these resources and
think what matters for you and how you
can set those goals to make
you move forward in in the
sustainability journey yeah second thing
so later this week Anna showed some of
the images from it but later this week
we're going to be publishing a website
where you can check out what the carbon
intensity of your local grid is in the
US and then of course you'll see the
difference if you come to Google Cloud
where we are essentially offsetting all
of those emissions so you can check out
you know essentially the difference
between plugging in a server on-premises
versus coming to Google cloud and what
that will be yeah depending on where you
are located the carbon intensity of the
grid is going to be completely different
depending on the type of generation
capacity that the grids have so you will
be able to see the differences between
where you could be placing your own data
center versus how it how your the carbon
intensity changes by moving to the cloud
it's pretty neat and then finally work
with your cloud provider right to see
where IT should be focused on not only
measuring sustainability but where you
can have an impact in future
sustainability goals and then if you
want to you can test out a carbon
neutral free trial on Google cloud by
going to cloud Google calm slash free so
that's a wrap thanks so much for
listening to the content we will be back
in a minute for Q&A thank you
you
all right so we got really good
questions from the audience and what
does it mean too much energy consumption
versus what it means to be powered with
renewable energy and we've been we've
been trying to be very clear about the
two differences because matching our
renewable energy consumption means that
we buy enough renewable power to match
every Mel watt hour of consumption that
we have if we were to say that we're
powered with renewable energy that would
mean that we're directly power that we
have enough solar drove or we have some
windmills that are directly hooked into
our data centers and as we discuss that
is currently unfortunately very hard to
do or virtually impossible because the
wind blows when it blows and the
sunshine Twitter chimes and we can just
say sorry called customer we can serve
you the wind isn't blowing that would
never work so there is a big difference
between matching and being powered with
the ultimate goal is that we can be
powered with a hundred percent of the
time renewable energy and we'll get
there eventually but we're quite just
not yet there yet because of the current
available technologies and how the grid
works yeah yeah the last question that
we got was what makes carbon offsets
high-quality and why we talk always
about Google's high quality carbon
offsets and again this is a program that
I ran so I'm very proud of it high
quality for us means highly additional
the project wouldn't have happened had
any been for the offsets and the reason
behind is if you we are claiming that
we're carbon neutral it means that we
got the reduction from somewhere else if
that reduction had happened anyway then
it's not additional we're not we can
claim carbon neutrality so in in
evaluating all of our carbon offset
projects I literally drive to every
single project that we have and I
evaluate the project that the
counterparts
the project developers etc to make sure
that the projects are run of the highest
quality that those companies are good
stores for the environment etc and
they're not causing any harm so we are
very proud of our 40-plus projects that
we partner with to obtain these high
quality carbon offsets that enable us to
be carbon neutral for our operations
yeah it's fantastic
alright so thank you so much for your
time we really had a lot of fun talking
about sustainability with you
stay tuned for the next session so it's
an amazing session with global fishing
watch and they're going to talk about
how they use Google cloud platform to
actually prevent overfishing right thank
you so much yeah